unsere neue ausgabe ist da und es ist
eine kleine aufforderung an die
deutschen lach doch mal
[Musik]
mein kollege philipp eppelsheim und ich
haben uns diese woche eine recht
skurrile recherchereise inaktive vor
einiger zeit gemacht haben
wir sind eher zufällig in der total
abgerockten fischer kneipe in cuxhaven
gelandet und mittendrin saß ein fischer
wie aus dem bilderbuch mit kapitänsmütze
und weißem bart und er hat zwei stunden
lang einfach nur kette geraucht um die
welt verdammt schwalben seien
ausgestorben die bundesregierung gehören
die wand gestellt und erschossen die
rente reichen nicht zum leben usw usw
und nach zwei stunden wir waren schon
total fertig haben ihn gefragt bist du
eigentlich glücklich dann guckt er so
ein bisschen und sagte mir geht es gut
und da ist der eppelsheim wir uns
gefragt warum jammern die deutschen so
viel und haben sie eigentlich grund zu
jammern die großen fragen interessiert
haben waren müssen wir um unseren
wohlstand fürchten wird das land immer
krimineller sind dann ein flüchtling und
angela merkel schuld dafür mit
fachleuten gesprochen wenn man es durch
etliche statistiken geführt und die
ergebnisse die sind wirklich interessant
eins kann ich ihn schon mal verraten
viele deutsche ticken wie der kicker in
cuxhaven
nehmen sie sich ein paar minuten und
lesen unsere titelgeschichte in der
woche